one thing that has helped teams who hold
the first overall pick avoid the overall
financial damage that that does when you
get it wrong is the 2011 cba with the
rookie wage scale that reeled in the
amount of money that a jamarcus russell
or another bust gets at the top of the
draft and that leads to where we are
right now the new cba is moving closer
and closer to being adopted what you
need to know begins with the meeting
that happened last night between the nfl
and the nfl pa they met for roughly four
hours and then the nfl pa had a meeting
of its full board of player
representatives 32 members and as
georgia toll the nflpa spokesman tweeted
at 105 a.m eastern time the board voted
to send the proposed collective
bargaining agreement to the membership
for a vote now i'm told there's not
going to be a recommendation from the
board it was not a two-thirds
supermajority the vote i'm told was 17
yes
14 no
one abstention
they got just enough votes to push this
thing through because the union
announced on monday to all agents and
players that a majority of the board
needed to vote yes or they wouldn't send
it to the full union right 17 votes the
magic number they're going to send it to
the full union if at least half plus one
of 1900 dues paying members of the union
say yes there's a new cba and the belief
is they will and this will get wrapped
up and we'll start the new league year
on march 18 with a higher salary cap and
a promise of 17 games at some point
between 2021 and 2020. so to you what
what is the big selling point to the
players that you know i don't want to
say we had a drastic change but of
course we had the first vote of last
week that went to six five you know no
now the executive committee
that negotiated the deal said no six to
five which makes no sense but still
makes no sense exactly right now
with this what what do you think the
players their big fear is just to all
the things that you've mentioned the
fact that we're worried about drop in
ratings election year economy drop all
those things and the players are
realizing that and they just want to
strike now and like demori smith is kind
of pushing this well demora smith has
been behind the idea of this cba
proposal from the get-go he presided
over the negotiations there's a term
sheet i'm told he's signed off on it
which isn't binding but at least it
sends a message to the rest of the union
that the guy you hired to run the union
wants this deal so if he wants it like
this is very simple
if he recommends his deal and you don't
want it they either need a new executive
director or he needs a new client yeah
because
it's not working right it's not
happening if the people he serves don't
want to take his advice and at some
point he has to say i'm out or they have
to say you're out but as of right now
they're following his advice they've
understood i don't know what happened
yesterday between the nfl and the nflpa
yeah right i haven't seen anything to
suggest that any significant concessions
were made by the nfl it could just be
that
some very persuasive gentlemen
in the room jerry jones etc and maybe
they had a powerpoint presentation where
they showed the players here's what
happens if we delay this process
of
getting a deal done and moving toward
new tv deals here's what will happen
with the ratings in 2020 and here's what
will happen with the willingness of the
networks to give us big money if we're
operating from a position of weakness
not a position of strength like we are
now right and here are the economic
forecasts over the next year and a half
and the economy is going to have a
downturn and the dow's down 2 000 points
over the last two days things can change
quickly i i don't know how much of that
fear was used to get the players to
pivot to it but the way demore smith has
always considered this there's two deals
the deal with the league and the deal
with the networks and you combine them
and in his mind it's better to combine
them now than to combine them later
right period and and that's where it all
comes from and whatever
was said
barely worked
17 the magic number from the board of
player representatives said yes so you
know it a mission accomplished and now
it goes on to the full membership well i
mean listen i fully expected that the
owners were going to win this
negotiation i just don't want it to be a
slaughter fest that's the only thing i
ever worry about as a player i mean this
is their domain this this conversation
uh but but at the same time i am happy
that it's going in the right direction
selfishly as a fan you know selfishly
because of our job and hey of course the
nfl yeah it's on fire right now we talk
about it a lot it's king it's king of tv
it's king of all our sports in this
country and why not keep keep that
rolling while we got a hot hand here so
from that point that standpoint i am
happy about it i know there's going to
be a lot of things in the agreement that
i'm not going to be necessarily pleased
with well and once we dig into the nooks
and crannies we'll see what's in there
that is and isn't favorable to the
players but the bottom line is this
the owners do
own the league and there is no football
without the players
but you know when we get down to basic
concepts of strikes and replacement
players and supply versus demand there
are a lot more players who can slap on
that uniform
right yes and that we saw that in 1987
and i think that's the fundamental
leverage and there are other ways the
players can exert leverage and look it's
not going to come to that the good news
is we're not going to yeah we're not
going to deal with that we had to deal
with it in 2011.
we don't have to deal with it now and
you didn't have to deal with it then
because you weren't in the media you
were locked in a closet in foxboro i was
i wasn't even there yet i was actually
just still like you're still playing i
was like out of the league on getting
some calls from maybe some teams
thinking i might have an you know one
more chance one more year or whatever it
may be
uh but yeah that did not happen and so i
was not involved in that in that process
at all yes i was just sitting at home
observing basically
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports